rumors in high school when i was younger
i'm not gonna like you i'm guilty i've
been that guy
we're not gonna we're not gonna we're
not gonna get we're not gonna get we're
not gonna get into it yeah but i've i've
had some rumors spread about me and then
you just carried on to college and stuff
like we do that type of job i don't
think it would be like
anything serious like anything that you
could take legal action upon like oh
this guy
like it's kind of like university oh
this like it's a small university that
we have in new york right and if someone
has sex with someone
it's instant because it's just a small
campus so like the rumor the world gets
around quickly but i just like i don't
think they should be like legally but i
think it does exactly exactly you know
what i mean if it takes away
opportunities from you and yeah biggest
opportunities then you're you should be
that's
what would take your chances away from
you like unless unless like your
lecturers hear about like you doing some
crazy stuff the night before
yeah like yeah yeah
yeah yeah like if it's if it's like
something along the lines of like oh
this guy
yeah and her and her and her and then
all the time yeah no
but if it's like involving like drugs in
your career and stuff like that because
athletes and that kind of stuff yeah all
the time so it is is a bit of what are
you spreading type thing that will have
an effect on someone
have you guys ever
been in a situation where somebody
accused someone of someone and you
didn't really believe them like it
doesn't have to be a close friend but
just someone you knew
yeah
yeah
well i'll see you as well what what like
what happened
um it was a friend of mine not a friend
of mine a mutual friend of mine um who
said that she was pregnant
um and as a mutual friend
um i told my friend to ask her like yo
show us the test so we can help you
she refuses to show us the test
um for weeks like six weeks eight weeks
we say we'll come to the doctor's with
you he's like no i want no one there so
we show up the doctor there's no
appointment
and so after like five months we're like
was this true she's like no oh my god so
what was that like an attention i've had
i've heard the same thing but that was
an attention move but
the fact that we had to still feel sorry
for her because to go to that length
to do that
it takes a lot
so yeah
yeah wait you still felt sorry for her i
i felt sorry for her because you have to
be at a very low point in your life to
say first of all accuse this boy of
making you pregnant because he's on the
other side like show me the test as a
father he should be able to see the test
i just think you're like a bad person
you are but
you feel sorry for someone i don't feel
sorry for them
so
you're just such a nice person you're
such a nice person
i
man
like if i came to you and i was like oh
my gosh i'm pregnant
what would your first initial like
reaction be how far along are you
i would say
well
when did it happen my first initial
reaction to people i know is to believe
them i don't i don't naturally just
think people are crazy um yeah you know
then it's like you would have you have
to kind of but poke at that person to
kind of know
yeah yeah i mean it's it's more like
you don't always know the character of
people so you ask like questions right
how far along are you who's the dad and
if everything like lines up you kind of
yeah you naturally believe people
but
that's not something to really lie about
being pregnant why would you lie about
that especially when you tell the person
that you think is the father of the baby
because that puts him in a very
vulnerable position i can ruin a man as
well exactly because then he's got to
tell his his family
like all of this like
and then if it's not even true then you
you've had all that stress for no reason
literally
do you think that
men should be able to take a woman to
court for that for lying absolutely
pregnant
absolutely yeah
no because cause you're looking to know
because you got cause you gotta look at
it look at it this way right
she just told me that she's pregnant
right cool so now i've gotta go and like
you said tell you tell my family and
then they're gonna have a go at me and
then their family gonna go and they're
gonna want it and you know how like some
old old uh old testament family's like
oh i want to see a test i want to see
this i want to meet the girls parents
and stuff like that and then you go
through all that length through all that
trouble
to
ideally
basically ruin
and then
all of that just to find out that she's
not really pregnant absolutely i said
yeah absolutely you should be able to
take it to court
yeah i mean it does play a big role
that's a whole lot you gotta you gotta
look at it like this right let's say you
let's say for example you say you're
pregnant to me and i and i'm the dad
right yeah cool i go away and i do
whatever i gotta do now i dropped out of
university because right now i've got
work and supplies now i've got a job you
know what i mean and then you come and
find out you're not you know i mean
about life stuff like that no way
it's big it's too much of a big impact
to to carry that into someone else's
life not just your own that is
big
yeah do you what about if a girl had to
go to like do you think she should be
able to go to jail for that
i think i mean much
he gets like mad depressed he ends up
like killing himself and stuff because
because you made some mad rumor like
emotional damage yeah emotional damage
then she should be held accountable
because you've like you basically
sometimes
i mean yeah
how much do you think that there's gonna
be consequences they can't just be back
you can't be on
up a wild rumor and like ruin someone's
life
what if
he commits suicide after her just sent
like texting him and saying i'm pregnant
it's your baby she should still go to
jail jail for one message
okay see this is
yeah okay i just think there has to be
some level of accountability because i
just think the way i look at society is
like
if you take away the consequences for
anything there are shitty people that
are gonna abuse it and i just think
these days
we've taken away a lot of the
consequence for women with stuff like
believe all women with stuff like
even like the in court you know and even
just our society naturally empathizing
with women and you know taking them at
face value yeah but i feel like you
can't do that too much because then
you're putting rules and laws on every
single little thing like there'll be a
lot there'll be a law fir for everything
like you can't say this you can't do
that and then people will be restricted
yeah then you've got no freedom i'm not
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about just i'm just talking about women
getting equal sentencing for the same
crime
yeah or i'm talking about like even in
this conversation
most people didn't agree with me when i
said you should be able to hit a woman
back
i i didn't i refuse to answer that
because no comment is the best comment
you know what i'm saying
i was smack a [ __ ] if she got knife yo
that then it's different but i think
like troy says she slaps you then why
would you slap her back like pin her
down let her know you're the man yeah
just restrict her oh okay before she
hits me
no you can't try again do you know what
i mean there's nothing where you need to
now go we have damagers
we had a talk about a similar thing what
was it of course ago when we talked
about like oh you shouldn't be able to
like you shouldn't have to hit a woman
yet but you you need to go to as a man
you need to go to a certain length here
to where she needs to understand that no
matter how strong she thinks she is
she will get put down and you know i
mean like i'm saying yeah so if you're
not gonna if you're not gonna hit the
woman back even if you grab her wrist
and
or like or if you're gonna stay yeah you
know what i mean like
i don't know just to hit a woman i mean
you're gonna do some damage or at least
if i'm if i'm if it's me
and if i respond
some women right